people and I just think there's some
campaign to make women feel like we're
so special and so important even though
most of us are just average chicks that
aren't that special or aren't that
important and it's so funny because
whenever I bring this up whenever I say
to the chicks guys we're not that
special we're not that smart when we're
pretty average like if you say that to a
guy it's so funny because we've spent a
generation telling men they're idiots
like we'll just say oh he's guy he's
dumb and it's so funny because the guys
just kind of take it they just say okay
but if you tell a women women if you
tell women we're idiots and we're dumb
and we're just average and men are
smarter it's like this visceral reaction
it's like aha ah my life is so hard